[Musique]
kendo
rami
dans les manifs blake lively madrid une
autre façon bruyante de se faire
entendre
à sa façon il utilise sa moto pour
revendiquer le respect des droits des
afro américains
il se fait appeler nikki de baxter sa
passion le motocross acrobatique mais
pas n'importe où dans les rues de new
york
aussi spectaculaire et maîtrisée que
soit cette activité il est illégal est
considéré par certains comme une
nuisance publique dangereuse mais rien
pour enrayer sa popularité ces dernières
années
ces motards téméraire navigue entre le
risque d'arrestation par la police et
l'obtention de contrats et
commanditaires la primaube et aux hauts
faits
mais si ces acrobaties spectaculaires
lui ont sauvé la vie d'autres n'ont pas
eu la même chance
dans ce parc les policiers tolère la
prochaine génération de motocyclistes
qui s'exerce sous le regard attentif de
leur mentor et dans la rue c'est une
autre histoire même s'il dit n'avoir
jamais mis en danger qui que ce soit li
qui est ses collègues motards se font
régulièrement confisqués ou même
détruire les motos lors d'opérations
musclées des autorités qu'importe
puisque les récentes tensions raciales
autour de la mort de john floyd lui
donne un second souffle pour l'instant
son combat demeure celui de l'avancement
de son sport qui passe par une piste
urbaine de motocross pour quitter la rue
et non pas une question de temps selon
lui se faire entendre comme afro
américains en cette période de
contestation est la priorité
on
[Musique]